[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Boing.
I am denting the wall.
Hey guys, I'm Nate.
Welcome back to the workshop,
where today we're going to be making
a cool pocket-sized coin launcher
out of used gift cards.
This is a fun little weapon
that's built from things
you probably already
have lying around your house.
And it uses nickels as ammunition.
For any non-Americans out there,
a nickel is what we call our five-cent coin.
The actual launcher is made from
four rigid plastic cards,
two rubber bands, and some super glue.
We'll also use scissors to cut them up.
And of course, we're going
to need some nickels as our ammunition.
I recommend using used gift cards for this.
In the past, I've had a tendency
to throw away gift cards
when I'm finished with them.
But I did have these for arcade
cards left over from a trip.
They're the same size and thickness
as a gift card or a hotel key.
To start,  let's take
one of our cards, one of our coins,
and something with a straight edge
we can use to trace against.
Technically, you could probably use
just about any coin to make this shooter work.
I went with the nickels
for a couple of reasons.
One of which is that
the thickness of a nickel
is almost exactly
the same as two of the cards.
Whatever coin we're using,
we want to put that onto our card,
and then use our straight edge to draw
two parallel lines down the center of our card,
approximately the same width as our coin.
There's a little bit of extra
space to either side of our nickel,
but that won't be a problem.
I'm leaving about 80%
of the card just as straight lines,
then we'll make sort of a
curve flare on both sides.
We now want to cut along
the curve flared portion,
and meet up with the straight portion,
all the way across the card.
Our card will end up
divided into three sections.
Now we want to divide a
second card exactly the same way.
So let's fit our first card
center piece onto a second card,
and then trace the outline.
[Music]
You should now have two pieces
that are basically identical.
You can see how
nicely they line up.
There may be a few imperfections
where we didn't cut them
out quite perfectly the same,
but we'll be able to fix that later.
Now let's take some super glue,
and glue our two pieces together.
Super glue will react fairly
quickly with this type of plastic card.
So I find the easiest thing
to do is apply the glue to one card,
then line up two of the edges on the table,
and then press the cards together.
This will help make sure
you have them properly aligned,
and that you don't miss while
you're trying to glue them down,
because once they're glued,
you won't really be able to
adjust them back to straight.
Now let's grab another one of our cards,
and begin to glue on the four pieces
that we cut from the sides of this centerpiece.
We'll use a similar technique applying glue,
then lining up the edges
before we move the two pieces together.
[Music]
Now we do the same thing with
the two card pieces on the other side.
[Music]
We do want this Center piece to
fit nicely in the Gap that we've cut,
but oftentimes,
our gluing will be a little bit imperfect
or the sides will
just be a little too close.
And in that case,
we can take some sandpaper,
and just take down the edges
of the centerpieces a little bit.
Sand the center portion until it
doesn't catch or snag on any pieces of card.
Before we attach our last card
onto the three that we've
already attached together,
we want to cut out a
little bit of a notch at the bottom.
And that'll make it a lot easier
to grab onto our firing mechanism.
[Music]
With the notches
cut out of the bottom,
now let's glue our top card on
to the three we've already connected.
[Music]
The center tab should now fit easily
into the gap between the other cards.
We now need to add some spring power.
To do that, we're going
to be using a couple of rubber bands,
but we want to make sure
that they're going to stay in place
right where we put them.
Just by stretching our rubber band
over the cards,
We can see a
good spot to put the notches.
We don't want the
rubber band to be covering the gap,
because that's where
we're going to fire the nickels.
[Music]
To cut these four notches out,
We can use a knife,
or a saw, or a file.
The notches don't have to be very deep.
They just have to
hold a rubber band in place.
[Music]
With our notches cut,
we can now stretch the rubber band
between the notches on both sides,
and they should be held nicely in place.
Two normal rubber bands
should give us all the power we need
to launch our coins pretty far.
At this point, the basic version of
our coin launcher should be ready to use.
Let's give it a try.
To load in a coin,
let's just pull back
the launcher a little bit,
fit a nickel into the opening,
and then drag it back the rest of the way.
[Music]
That works great.
This thing works pretty well,
but I've got a couple
ideas of some upgrades
that will make it work a lot better.
I would say the two biggest problems
are that it can be a little bit hard
to hold on to
since it's such slick plastic.
And of course, that you have to
reload the coin individually every time.
And I think we've got solutions
for both of those problems.
I have here the two pieces of plastic
that I cut off of the ends of the card
that make it easier
to grab on to the launcher.
Let's cut out a
small piece from each of these
and glue them on to
the back of the launcher on both sides
so it's a little
bit easier to hold on to.
[Music]
Those two notches should
give us much better grip.
We also want to make the body
of our coin launcher easier to hold on to.
Let's see if we
can cut a couple of notches
into the sides of our coin launcher
that makes it easier to grip.
This curved file should give us
a nice profile that's easy to hold.
[Music]
These two curved notches
are easy to fit my fingers into,
and they give much better grip.
That solves our first problem
of how easy it is to hold on to
the coin launcher.
But at this point,
we're still loading our nickles individually,
And I've got a good solution
for how to get past that as well.
We can add a semi-automatic
launching attachment onto the card.
But to do so will require
a little bit of surgery.
We're going to have
to remove the top card,
drill a hole into it,
and then glue it back in place.
Let's use an exacto knife to see
if we can fit it in between
the top card and the next layer down,
and see if we can split through
the superglue to get this off.
Now of course,
if you're going to be making
these modifications at home,
you can just do this from the beginning,
and add all of this before
you glue it on in the first place.
When we're firing our launcher,
pulling it back about that
far seems to be a good distance.
We can see that the curved notch
we've cut out of the card
goes right about like that.
So if we have a hole
the exact size of a nickel
just above there,
we should be able to drop
nickels down into our launcher
through a hole in the top
just by pulling back the firing mechanism.
To drill that hole,
I have a 7/8 inch Forstner bit.
And we're going to be using that size
because it's just barely larger than
the diameter of a nickel.
[Music]
That line will mark where
we should start drilling that hole.
To be able to drill
cleanly through our card,
let's secure it in
place to a block of wood,
and that whole block to our desk.
That should let us
drill nicely into it
without it moving around too much.
Alright, right about here,
It looks like our bit is fitting
nicely between all of our markings.
So let's start drilling.
[Music]
There we go.
We are through.
That might take a little
bit of cleaning up with a razor blade.
[Music]
Perfect fit.
The nickel just drops right through there.
Let's also hit that
with a little bit of sandpaper
to take off the burr.
[Music]
If we line all of the pieces
of our launcher back up together,
we can see how this will
work to drop coins down inside.
You have a nickel on top,
when we draw it back,
nickel drops in
and then gets fired out the front.
But we don't want just one nickel
to be able to launch from the top.
We want to add a whole magazine on to this.
And so to do that,
we're going to cut off
the neck of a standard water bottle
and attach that on
to the top of the cards.
Stay hydrated kids.
Most standard water or soda bottles,
should be able to fit a nickel nicely
through without much space on the sides.
[Music]
After we cut off the
neck of the water bottle,
we want to remove any of the plastic
that starts flaring out sideways.
We don't want these
pieces that get wider.
We just want the same width
of the neck all the way down.
I'm doing some rough
trimming with the razor blade,
and then we'll move on to using some
sandpaper to get a nice even flat edge.
[Music]
The bottom of our bottleneck is sanded,
and it should fit just perfectly over
that hole we drilled into our card.
Let's use some super glue
to glue that in place on to our card,
and then glue that top card back
in place on to our coin launcher.
[Music]
Just to reinforce the connection
between the neck of
the bottle and the top card,
let's go around
the base with some hot glue
because the plastic is so thin.
That should be a little bit more secure
of an attachment than just super glue.
With the bottle neck,
we now have a magazine
that could hold up to seven nickels,
And we can put a lid on top of it,
so they don't spill out
while we're carrying this around.
Some taller types of water bottle neck
may be able to hold even more.
[Music]
We've got one thing left
to do before testing this out,
and that of course is to paint it.
We love to give things a
little bit of decoration here.
Let's just lightly hit the surface
with some sandpaper first
to make the paint grip nicer.
I'm going to paint it
with the firing mechanism in,
which wi'll add some
black paint on to the back of it,
but won't get any paint onto the body of it.
That's because if there
was paint on the body of it,
it could bind up inside the mechanism.
[Music]
Our coin shooter is painted up,
and ready for some firing.
Let's load up our ammunition.
[Music]
Oops, pulled that too far.
If you want additional power,
try just adding
a second rubber band each side.
[Music]
That was way better.
This mifty little coin shooter is
just made out of
a few cards and a rubber band.
And if you want the added magazine,
a piece of a water bottle.
It works really well,
it fits in your pocket
and it can carry up to seven shots
with just the short little
water bottle neck that I have on it.
And like I said,
you can probably
extend that magazine size
by just using a taller water bottle neck.
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
just hit the bomb to get in the club.
If you missed our last video,
or want to see it again,
click up here at the top.
Click down there at the bottom
to see what the internet thinks
that you are supposed to watch next.
That's it for today.
Have fun.
Be safe and see you tomorrow.
[Music]